STEPHANIE WONG:
Today, we're talking
about game-changing automation
with GKE, BigQuery BI Engine,
and keeping the Cloud safe.
I'm Stephanie Wong, and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud," where
we serve you the
lowest-latency news.
Organizations that need the
highest levels of reliability,
security, and scalability
for their applications
choose Google Kubernetes
Engine, or GKE.
Until now, Kubernetes
still involved a fair bit
of manual assembly and tinkering
to optimize it for your needs.
We're introducing GKE
Autopilot, a revolutionary mode
of operations for
managed Kubernetes that
lets you focus on your software
while GKE Autopilot manages
the infrastructure, like
autoscaling and auto-upgrades
of nodes plus Day 2 operations.
We're also extending
BigQuery BI Engine
to work with any business
intelligence or custom
dashboarding
applications that require
sub-second query response times.
In this preview, BI Engine
will work seamlessly
with Looker and other
popular BI tools
without requiring any change
to the BI tools themselves.
Not only is BI Engine
now natively integrated
into the BigQuery API.
You can also reserve BI Engine
capacity in your own GCP
project.
Check out the announcement
for more info.
This podcast will bring
you stories and insights
on security in
the Cloud and what
we're doing at Google
Cloud to help keep customer
data safe and workloads secure.
We'll do our best to cut to
the heart of real security
questions and issues.
If you have topics you're
interested in hearing about,
listen to the podcast
and let us know.
Need a quick overview of
Google Cloud Core Technologies?
Quickly learned these 21 Google
Cloud products from Anthos
to Pub/Sub, each explained
in under two minutes.
Check out the blog to read
more and see the videos.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.